What was your purpose of posting your
photos flying in a private jet plane and
traveling in a bulletproof car with so
many security on the social media during
your lecture tour to Nigeria in November
2023? Is this not showing off an
extravagance? We love you for your
davawa, not for your luxury and
extravagance. This is a very important
question. It's referring to my lecture
tour to Nigeria from the 29th of October
to the 10th of November. It was for
about 2 weeks and the lecture was very
successful and I remember that I posted
on the social media twice that I flew on
a private jet plane from SooKoto to
Elorin once and second time from Elorin
to Abuja. And when I posted this on my
social media on the Facebook, on the
Instagram etc. there were thousands of
comments and alhamdulillah most of them
saying mashallah may Allah reward you.
You're doing a great work. May Allah
bless you. May Allah give you more
yama. More than 99% of the comments were
all positive. There were small few
comments maybe 0.0001% 001% of the
thousands of comments that came the
number very few who did say that why are
you posting that you're flying in a
private jet plane isn't it
extravagance what is the purpose and
that is the reason I chose this question
was asked that Allah says in the Quran
in surah bakar chapter number two verse
number 271 that when you give charity
and you announce about the charity you
have given it is good but when you let
your charity reach to the poor people In
secrecy it is better. So Allah says when
you give charity you can keep it secret
like the hadith says when your right
hand gives the left hand should not
know. It's good but that doesn't mean
announcing is not
allowed. Depending on your purpose if
your purpose is to show off then
announcing is not good. But if your
purpose is to encourage others when you
give charity and when you announce and
you encourage others it's good because
your main nia is so that other people
also join in charity other people get
sab so if your reason for announcing
your charity is to show off that okay
I've given charity it's not good better
is to keep quiet but if you're
announcing so more people join so it is
better to announce than to keep silent
and that is the reason you may be aware
that just two weeks earlier I won the
case against one of the
politicians that is the former deputy
chief minister too of Pinang I won a
case against him many defamed me wrote
articles against me and the court of
Malaysia awarded me 1.52 million ringit
as damages that's equal to
$320,000 equal to 2.7 cr Indian rupees.
What I did and he already gave me the
money on the 7th of November and I
donated the complete amount for the
Palestinian
cause. The reason I announced is so that
it encourages the others also to take
part that I have done and others will
follow. It wasn't to show off.
Similarly, now when you analyze that I
did post twice on two occasions that I
traveled in a private jet plane. If you
know my talks, I always talk about
simplicity. There should not be
extravagance. They should not be
unnecessary luxury. If you talk about
extravagance, let me tell you, I did not
pay a single penny for this private jet
plane.
The host was flying in the private jet
plane. There were already 13 seats. So
me and my family joined them. If you
wouldn't have joined them, maybe we
would have to pay for the flight ticket
for going by a conventional or a
commercial plane. So to say that I spent
extra is totally wrong. I did not spend
extra. I saved money. So it's not
extravagance at all. But why did I post
it? If you see that I always say and I
tell the people that see to it that your
life should be simple even though you
can afford a business class travel
economic class and I do that by Allah's
grace I can afford to travel in first
class but what I tell the people you
travel in economic class a business
class normally is four to six times more
expensive than economic class if you
travel an economic class with little bit
discomfort it's not very bad you can
give that amount in charity and that's
What I do in my full life only on one
occasion when there was an emergency I
had to be in that city and there was no
tickets available in economy I traveled
only once in my full life in the last 30
years of my travel have I paid for a
business class that's a different thing
that when I'm called as a guest of the
government and they give me a ticket in
business class in first class I've
traveled a lot I've been private jet
plane many
times number of times not that I asked
for it. The reason is because today the
world has become a global
village and you find that there's a
trend that you see in the social media
whether it be Facebook whether it be
Instagram, WhatsApp, YouTube that people
try and look for role models and we find
that unfortunately most of the people
that people follow they are those who
are not on the state part whether they
be rock singers whether they be actors
whether they may be dancers whether pop
singers or maybe sportsmen etc. So what
we find that this trend is there. So the
reason I did is that
alhamdulillah by the grace of Allah
subhanana wa tala in the post itself.
Alhamdulillah mashallah that the grace
of Allah when you find that normally
these things happen with those
celebrities who people look up to. So
here my reason main was posting it to
see that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives
the nyama even to his servants. So the
main reason was not to show off. The
main reason was to tell to the world
that when you work in the path of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala when you strive in
the path of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
when you go to spread his message Allah
not only gives you blessings in the
Allah gives you in this world as Allah
says in the Quran that if you strive for
this duny Allah says in surah bakar
chapter number two verse number 200 that
if you strive for this duny Allah will
give you the duny but will not give you
a and Allah says that if you strive for
a Allah I give you and so I'm just
telling the world that I am a d I have
sacrificed my life for Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala I'm doing it for a but see the
goodness of Allah subhanana wa tala see
the nyama of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
that inshallah inshallah Allah will give
me inshah we pray for that we don't know
but we pray for that but Allah is even
giving me this dy how many people in the
world have traveled in a private jet
plane maybe 0001% Out of the 8 billion
people that are there, the percentage
that may have traveled in a private jet
plane is surely 0001%. So imagine Allah
we're not doing for this. I have never
ever paid only once for a business never
paid for a first though we can afford
it. Allah has given us. So the reason is
to show that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
even blesses those people who are
striving in. What we have today is that
we look up to role models and the best
role model for the Muslims is Mhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam. Our beloved
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is the best role model and
after that the other ambias the second
category of role models are the far they
are the second. After the Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam one then the
other ambias then we have the khulfar.
They are the second best. Then we have
the sabas. These role models are of the
past. Then we have role models of the
recent past. Then we have the role
models which are living. So the reason
that we see today is that it happened in
the past. Okay, we know regarding the
earlier answer that we know that Allah
gave victory to the people who are weak
in the past. What about today that
happened maybe 1400 years ago, 1,000
years ago, maybe few thousand years ago.
talking about David and Gulat talking
about battle of bad but Allah has given
examples even we know about the Taliban
for more than 20
years the most richest country the most
powerful country in the world they tried
to destroy them they spent more than a
trillion dollars but yet the Taliban
were one of the weakest in the world
they were victorious so here you see
that it is an example that people strive
in the way of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
we don't go for luxury what Allah gives
you. So the purpose of mine was just to
show the nyama that Allah has given to a
person who's walking in this path. And
the reason I said that we traveled in a
bulletproof car with securities we could
see that there were empty number of
security in Nigeria. Not that someone is
going to attack me. Alhamdulillah people
Nigeria love me. But this is a protocol
that not only do they give this protocol
to the head of states etc. But even to a
dai I remember when I went to Gambia the
amount of respect that the president of
Gambia gave me his main chief protocol
officer said that the protocol that you
had got even the heads of state don't
get I went to Indonesia and I could see
that when I landed when I reached my
hotel after every 50 m there was a
policeman so from the time where I
landed to my destination that is the
hotel there were hundreds or thousands
of policemen on the streets I was
shocked never ever have I been in such a
protocol that there are policemen every
25 50 m throughout for so many
kilometers. I was shocked. So this is
their love. So this is a nyama of Allah
subhana wa
tala to show to the world that you
strive in the way of Allah subhananaa
tala. Allah gives you honor. We have the
celebrities, these pop stars, the
singers, their 1 million followers, 5
million followers, 10 million followers,
20 million followers. So Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala also can give
ad millions of followers whether it be
on the Facebook whether it be on the
YouTube. So when we see
alhamdulillah that on my Facebook there
are
23.7 million followers there is no
English religious speaker in the world
whether it be a Hindu or a Christian or
a Muslim that Allah has given more than
23 million followers and alhamdulillah
it's a blessing from Allah subhana wa
tala it is not to show off it is to show
that you strive in the way of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala Allah opens the
pathways so when I posted me traveling
in a private jet plane which a small
percentage 0001% of the people in the
world have done it or having a
bulletproof car with so much security
it's an honor it's a protocol so the
reason was to show to the world that the
honor that Allah gives you in this world
and a so it is to give an indication to
the
Muslims that you strive in the path of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala you strive If
a Allah will give a and this dunya also
so that was the only purpose that is the
reason more than 99% of the comments
said mashallah may Allah grant you more
they understood the reason there may be
01% of the people like the question it
what was the purpose they don't
understand hikma because I always tell
and I tell that a person should have a
low profile and I tell that Allah has
blessed me even in this dunya but in
spite of that we on a low profile and
I've told that many times in my lecture
that I own a Toyota Innova car that is
the maximum I said I cannot buy a more
expensive car than this why because I
feel above this will not be good it's
not haram Allah has best me when I am
earning millions of ringit and millions
of real every year so easily I can
afford a Mercedes or I can even afford a
Rolls-Roy the amount that Allah has
blessed me but I own a Toyota Inovakad
that's the maximum I think above this
will not be good it's not right but we
know that we started business in Qatar
during the world cup that is last year
in 2022 and we started a luxury car
company in Qatar for the world cup and
it happened to be the largest luxury
rental car and by Allah's grace we owned
134 luxury cars from the top models from
rose Rollsroy, Lamborghini, Bentley,
Bentley Flyingspur, Bentega,
Mayback, Mercedes S450, we had the
Porsche. Alhamdulillah, that is for
business. Imagine the cheapest car that
I had in my peace rental car that was
there. The cheapest car was three times
more expensive than the car I own for my
private use, you know, Toyota. Three
times more expensive. So much so that
when I went to meet my daughter in Kar,
I took the lowest car that is Mercedes
E-Class E200, the cheapest car in my
fleet because hiring outside I had to
pay money. It was available. So I took
the cheapest car and I saw to it that I
travel in the lowest car if I'm using my
car. I could have traveled in the best
of cars and now I've purchased a more
cheaper car so that if I travel it
should be a cheaper car but when a D
comes and I made it a point that now
since the world cup is over the business
is not really very lucrative but I yet
maintained it so that there's no profit
no loss but at the same time any D that
comes to whether he be an Arabic D or an
English D if he is an Islamic worker
these cars are complimentary and many a
time many D have come from different
parts of the world we give In the west
of car, not luxury car, super luxury
car. They sit in a Maybback. They sit in
a Bentley. Imagine hiring a Bentley or a
Maybback or a Rolls-Roy for a day it is
$9,000 real. That is
$25,000. Of course, for a normal person,
it's it's rough. It's extravagance. But
that's business. We are catering to the
multi-millionaires or the billionaires.
So, that's a niche market. But when a D
comes, I give him free. For me it's
costing only the cost of the petrol
because the car is there, the driver is
there. If no one comes yet the car is
there, no cost. So for me the cost is
only of petrol which may be 60 hours,
maybe $15. So I give the best car to the
D depending upon the
D and they have never sat most of the D
in these high-end luxury cars. So I want
to honor them. It is not for luxury
extravagance. It's because you're a dai
I give you free. Of course, you cannot
afford $25,000 a day. It's too
expensive. Your air ticket economic
class will be cheaper than that from
whichever part of the world you come to
Qatar. It will surely be less than
$25,000 for one day and we're there for
one week. We give the full. So one of
the reasons that we have maintained this
rent the car in Qatar is to give free
service to the dies. Of course traveling
or using these super luxury cars like
Rolls-Royce, Lamborghini, Bentley very
few people have but I personally don't
sit in these cars though we own
it. The company is in the name of my
son. It's not in my name but I'm just
giving an example. We want to honor the
D. So similarly when people who own the
jet planes I remember when a person had
sent his jet plane in South Africa to
take I said that instead of cost of that
you can give donation they say no no I
give to celebrities what better sabup
can I give than to give a d like you in
the world. So here Allah is giving his
nyama. So when we have these postings
besides the hundreds of other postings,
this is just a couple of post each time
to show to the world that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is blessing a person
who works in his path. It is an example
for the people that this is the nyama
Allah gives you in that. So it is just
to show to the world that Allah subhana
takes care of you. You see to it that
you don't be extravagant yourself in
your life but Allah will yet give you
luxury. So it's a blessing that my
children we have traveled to various
countries in the world. They have been
in the best of hotels fivestar, sixstar,
sevenstar, 10star hotel. They have been
there at the same time they have been to
the low hotels. We have trained them
that they should be ready as a dai to be
prepared to lead a simple life. That's
the reason I've said many a time that me
personally for me and my wife our
monthly expenditure is only $500. Only
$500 so that we keep our lifestyle low
but for the cause of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala when we travel we see to it that
we spend in the way of Allah and Allah
is giving us so all this
is this is because of the grace of Allah
subhanaa tala. So the main purpose of
putting the post whether it be private
jet planes or the security or the
bulletproof car is to show that Allah is
blessing his servants. Hope that answers
the question.